[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute ein sehr
beliebtes Gericht und zwar marklube das
heißt umgedreht warum es den Namen
kluber hat das erzähle ich euch
beziehungsweise zeige ich euch am Ende
des Videos ich starte jetzt direkt mit
meinem Rezept ihr könnt euch die ganz
genauen Mengenangaben unten in der
Infobox ansehen screenshotten und direkt
einkaufen gehen und eure Einkaufsliste
gebe jetzt hier Öl in meinen Topf der
sollte schon ausreichend groß sein weil
gleich das Fleisch darin gebraten wird
das machen wir erst vorab anschließend
geht's noch im Wasser gegart und ich
gebe jetzt hier zu allererst
Knoblauchzehen rein die könnt ihr fein
hacken oder pressen das ist ganz euch
überlassen ich presse jetzt und dann
gebe ich noch sehr sehr leckere
orientalische Gewürze mit dazu ich habe
heute mein 7 gewürzt das ist eine
fertige Gewürzmischung das kennen auch
viele aus dem südländischen Bereich wenn
ihr das nicht kennt ich verlinke euch in
der Infobox schreibe euch aber auch
Alternativen rein falls ihr das gerade
nicht habt oder euch einfach die Zeit
viel zu bestellen dann schreibe ich euch
in die Infobox was ihr stattdessen
nehmen können das ist dann nicht eins zu
eins so aber es ist auch eine gute
Alternative aber ich werde jetzt erstmal
hier den Knoblauch so ein zwei Minuten
lang rösten und dann gebe ich meine
Gewürze mit dazu
da kommen jetzt Kardamom Kapseln eine
Zimtstange und Lorbeerblätter mit dazu
die machen es halt am Ende also wenn
dann schaut euch wirklich mal so eine
Packung Kardamom Kapseln oder frischen
Zimt an ich finde das macht immer schon
ein gewaltigen Unterschied und da kommt
jetzt eben das besagte sieben Gewürz mit
rein das sind einfach sieben Gewürze in
einem Mix und das gebe ich jetzt dazu
das gibt's auch von also das ist jetzt
meine eigene ist auch schon wieder
lehrreich dass ich sie auch benutze es
gibt ganz viele verschiedene Firmen
jetzt müsst ihr natürlich wissen dass
jede Firma oder jeder Produzent das in
einem anderen Verhältnis mischt das
heißt es schmeckt nicht immer identisch
nur dass ihr das im Hinterkopf habt und
da gebe ich jetzt mein Fleisch mit dazu
am besten nehmt ihr Hähnchenkeulen
Hähnchen Oberschenkel am besten mit Fett
das habe ich jetzt gewaschen das gebe
ich jetzt direkt mit dazu und dann wird
das von beiden Seiten oder von allen
Seiten so 3 Minuten lang angebraten ihr
wäre das Wasser dazu kippen Salz hätte
ich fast vergessen das gebe ich jetzt
auch schon mit dazu und dann wird das
Ganze wie gesagt angebraten hier habe
ich auch noch Hähnchenteile ohne Knochen
zwei Stück also ihr könnt auch ganz gut
mixen aber am besten immer mit Fett
[Musik]
so das Fleisch habe ich jetzt noch mit
Wasser bedeckt den Deckel drauf gegeben
und jetzt darf das 20 Minuten lang
köcheln es kommt natürlich immer auf die
dicke das Fleisch an vielleicht brauchst
du auch 2 Minuten länger und zwei
Minuten oder zwei Minuten kürzer es wird
auf jeden Fall jetzt im kochenden Wasser
gegart und in der Zwischenzeit kümmern
wir uns um unser Gemüse den ganz
traditionell wird das Gemüse frittiert
also entscheidet ihr euch einfach für
Gemüse eurer Wahl ich nehme am
allerliebsten Blumenkohl Aubergine und
Kartoffeln Kartoffeln dürfen niemals
gehen und das ganze wird jetzt einfach
nur also Blumenkohl mit kleines
geschnitten oder ein kleine Röschen
geteilt Aubergine wird auch so ein
bisschen geschält und dann in Scheiben
geschnitten genauso wie die Kartoffeln
dann nehme ich vorwiegend festkochende
und anschließend oder vorher natürlich
waschen und ähm schön trocknen in das
ganze wird dir anschließend im Fett
frittiert bis alles schön goldbraun ist
[Musik]
ihr könnt jetzt übrigens ganz gut
parallel arbeiten denn während mein
Frittierfett erhitzt habe ich hier schon
mal Kartoffeln und Auberginen
geschnitten und mache mich jetzt an den
Blumenkohl ran und ihr könnt natürlich
auch jegliches Gemüse eurer Wahl nehmen
alles was sie mögt alles was man da noch
mit reingehen kann ich nehme zum
Beispiel manchmal auch ganz gerne Möhren
muss ich sagen und was ich heute mit
dazu gebe deswegen war es jetzt am
Anfang auch noch nicht in meinem Kopf
ich nehme noch Zwiebeln dazu die werde
ich gleich auch noch mal in feine
Scheiben schneiden oder in feine Stränge
und dann wird es auch mit frittiert und
mit geschichtet
[Musik]
die 20 Minuten sind jetzt auch rum ich
nehme jetzt hier das Hähnchen einmal
raus
das wird natürlich gleich wieder
geschichtet in den Topf aber wir
brauchen ja den Topf einmal leer und wir
brauchen unser würziges hühnersoße ich
nehme die Kardamom Kapseln und so weiter
die lasse ich jetzt noch drinne die
würzen dann gleich auch noch automatisch
das ganze Gericht noch mal also auch den
Reis und so weiter daher auf jeden Fall
alles drin lassen Fleisch entnehmen und
den Sud einfach in eine separate
Schüssel umfüllen und dann brauchen wir
wie gesagt den Topf gleich zum Schichten
[Musik]
so jetzt habe ich ja alles ausfrittiert
und wir können Schichten es ist gleich
sehr entspannt denn der Herd erledigt
gleich alles von alleine und wir müssen
den Reis auch nicht vorgaren deshalb
finde ich auch so entspannt das einzige
was ein bisschen Vorarbeit ist ist das
ganze frittiert aber das geht auch super
schnell so und jetzt habe ich hier den
Topf von gerade eben ich habe den auch
nicht ausgewaschen ich fange jetzt
direkt an hier zu schichten und gebe als
allererstes das Fleisch hier einmal auf
den Boden das ist jetzt hier natürlich
schon abgekühlt was macht ihr nicht es
wird ja gleich wieder alles gekauft und
das Geld das ganze funktioniert
natürlich auch mit Rindfleisch und so
weiter sie müsst euch da nicht festlegen
das könnt ihr völlig nach eurem eigenen
Belieben machen so und da gebe ich jetzt
einmal die Kartoffeln oben drüber und
auch hier in die Zwischenräume damit das
eine schöne glatte Oberfläche ergibt und
dann könnt ihr einfach weiter Schichten
ganz zum Schluss kommt erst euer Reis
dazu und ich rate euch natürlich immer
so eine zu einem guten Topf mit einer
sehr guten Antihaftbeschichtung bei mir
mache ich mir zum Beispiel überhaupt
keine Sorgen da brennt nichts an der
klebt nichts an einige machen gekriegt
wenn sie nicht so gute Töpfe haben die
machen dann Backpapier unten drunter so
als Notlösung sage ich mal und das würde
auch gehen aber ich meine selbst wenn
was kleben bleibt weil ihr nicht in
idealen Topf habt dann ist das so also
macht euch da einfach keinen Stress
[Musik]
ich arbeite jetzt natürlich mit sauberen
Händen daher Schichte ich das auch alles
in meinen Händen ich habe jetzt ganz
oben noch die Zwiebeln drauf gegeben und
ihr könnt mit den Handinnenflächen alles
nochmal schön flach andrücken und ganz
zum Schluss kommt Reis mit dazu den
müsst ihr allerdings vorbereiten
eigentlich kennt ihr das aus meinem
Reisevideos so lange mit lauwarmem
Wasser oder kaltem Wasser das ist egal
ausspülen bis unten das Wasser fast klar
wieder rauskommt ganz klar wird es nie
aber es sollte auf jeden Fall nicht mehr
so trüb sein damit könnt ihr einfach
verhindern dass es später so anklebt
denn die Stärke ist dann rausgespült und
die Stärke bringen den Reisinger dazu
dass er so klebrig wird und also ich
persönlich mag halt in dem Fall einfach
lieber lockeren und körnigen Reis ich
habe übrigens Basmati Langkornreis die
mag ich hier ganz gerne bei dem Gericht
so und jetzt gebe ich hier noch die
Gewürze mit dazu und zwar einmal Salz
und was Sie auf jeden Fall dazu gehen
könnt ist Ras el hanut das ist ein
Gewürz ist heute für meine Schwiegermama
kennengelernt und das schmeckt bei Reis
so lecker ich habe es euch ganz oft auf
Instagram auch gezeigt das bringt den
Reis einfach noch so mal auf so ein
anderes Level ich kann es euch gar nicht
beschreiben ihr müsst das einfach mal
probieren das ganze rühre ich jetzt gut
durch und dann gebe ich das hier auch
einfach oben drüber und dann wird das
ganze mit dem hühnersoße bedeckt bzw auf
jeden Fall noch ein bisschen Wasser
nachgießen
[Musik]
und ihr merkt schon ich drücke es die
ganze Zeit runter was auch hilft ist
einfach einen Teller so ein schweren so
ein hitzebeständiger da drauf zu tun das
hilft halt einfach nur man kennt ihr so
ähnlich von den gefühlten Weinblättern
kann ich euch das Rezept ja mal
verlinken falls ihr darauf Lust habt
einfach zu beschweren und jetzt kommt da
unser Hühnersuppe dazu und so viel
Wasser bis es den Reis so ca ein
Zentimeter überdeckt und dann sollten
wir das ganze auch auf jeden Fall auch
hier die ganzen Gewürzen das ganze auf
jeden Fall einmal aufkochen damit es auf
Temperatur kommt ich arbeite hier voll
traditionell mit den Händen ich merke
das schon normalerweise in den Videos ja
alles ganz feinen Teigschaber das ist
jetzt auch Traditionsküche so und da
gebe ich jetzt noch Wasser wie gesagt
mit dazu ein Zentimeter beim Reis dann
das Ganze einmal schön aufkochen lassen
das muss auf Temperatur kommen und dann
runter auf Stufe 3 von 9 mit
geschlossenem Deckel ca 40 bis 45
Minuten lang so lange garen lassen bis
der Reis eben komplett gar ist
[Musik]
nach einer dreiviertel Stunde auf dem
Herd müsste unser Gericht fertig sein
jetzt gibt es aber noch zwei Dinge zu
beachten einmal sollte das ganze jetzt
so noch 10 Minuten ruhen einfach damit
es noch mal sackt und ein bisschen
nachzieht ich werde jetzt aber dafür den
Teller einmal entfernen und dann das
ganze noch mal so ein bisschen leicht
flach andrücken und dann wie gesagt noch
mal 10 Minuten ruhen lassen und
anschließend kommt das anschließend
kommt das wofür man kluge eben mal Probe
heißt nämlich umgedreht wir drehen das
ganze um und da sollte es dann auch noch
mal 10 Minuten ruhen das sind nur die
zwei Dinge die noch beachten solltet und
dann seid ihr eigentlich ready
[Musik]
also eigentlich jetzt noch mal 10
Minuten warten eine Unterlage die gerade
ist es hilfreicher meine geht hoch
deswegen kommt am Rand der Reis schon
raus aber das ist nicht schlimm also 10
Minuten und dann hoch machen
ein bisschen Trommel
das müsst ihr mal sagen wieso juhu das
ist ein Brauch so ein traditioneller
arabischer brauch
also meine Mutter
und du musst einmal ganz zum Schluss
musst du noch mal so machen
ja den heißen Topf
[Applaus]
mega zack mit einem Teigschaber das ist
meine Mutter gemacht
ich habe noch nebenbei Cashewkerne
geröstet viele Frittieren sie auch oder
Frittieren auch Mandeln da haben wir
schon viel frittiert deswegen geröstet
finde ich auch vollkommen okay wir
verteilen noch ein bisschen
ja ich hatte sogar erstmal
Bock auf Cashewkerne und darüber dann
noch für die Optik ein bisschen
Petersilie und fertig
perfekt perfekt
ich bin richtig happy ich hatte so ein
bisschen Angst dass es so aber das ist
immer so diese Angst ist immer da du
kannst das gut aber stolz auf Dich
gleich
[Musik]
stolz auf mich
den richtigen Tipp dazu passt übrigens
Salat das war's das ist alles schon drin
also daher braucht ihr gar keine
Beilagen ehrlich einen Salat frischer
Salat reicht vollkommen und es sollte
jetzt der saftig sein
und das Fleisch ich habe gerade schon
jetzt schon gesehen ich habe so
auseinander gezogen
wenn unsere Mütter können alle gut
kochen aber ich mag das auch mit Blumen
drin
Schwiegermutter Mama Tante Onkel alle
werden euch lieben und viel Spaß und was
machst du viel davon essen
können
sogar acht sagen
also es ist halt er macht einmal für
mehrere und das ist immer so super
praktisch
zum Beispiel mit so einer Suppe dazu
das stimmt
nicht also acht Männer nicht aber so 44
also vier Frauen die Männer auf jeden
Fall cool
gedreht auch wir leiden während wir
meine essensrezepte anschauen
auf jeden Fall zu 100 % richtig geil
okay dann wünsche ich Euch sehr viel
Spaß beim Nachkochen und sage bis zum
nächsten mal auf meinem Kanal tschüss
und übrigens meine ganze Verwandtschaft
in deine Aussicht
[Musik]